boa tarde agradeço muito essa
oportunidade de poder tá aqui pensando
alto
junto com vocês em primeiro lugar eu
queria agradecer o paulo saldiva a gente
combinou tudo então vai engatar na fala
dele a gente finge que não mas vai
engatar na fala dele e vocês vão
entender por que e fazer um pequeno
reparo na minha apresentação e dizer que
meu último o último livro que eu lancei
que a guerra dos lugares da editora
boitempo ele é muito a base daquilo que
eu vou falar agora aqui pra você pra mim
é o que está mais néné vibrando é no meu
coração e nesse momento é o paulo
terminou a fala dele professor paulo
terminou a fala dele falando né daquilo
que tá em sintonia com a vida e daquilo
que provoca na gente a vida e entre os
vários elementos que ele colocou nos
afectos às relações emocionais
ele falou da importância da existência
de uma vida prazerosa
no espaço da cidade ambiente prazeroso
no espaço da cidade como um elemento
fundamental pra poder reproduzir a vida
e poder reproduzir essa vida com
qualidade e é exatamente por isso e
tomando esse gancho dele que eu quero
dizer por que entender a cidade como um
produto numa prateleira do supermercado
a venda vai contra a ideia da cidade
como lugar da vida e da reprodução da
vida e do desenvolvimento da vida e do
acolhimento da vida é e vou tentar muito
rapidamente
a isso e esse é um debate absolutamente
central é hoje nessa cidade e não apenas
aqui em são paulo mas é um debate
central do nosso país é na medida em que
é nós estamos vivendo um momento onde ao
que tudo parece a lógica da definição do
destino dos lugares da cidade ou seja
cada lugar como ele vai ser ocupado cada
lugar
como ele vai é ser vivido pelas pessoas
está cada vez mais subordinada a uma
lógica a rentabilidade do capital
investido naquele lugar que que
significa isso significa subordina toda
a ampla possibilidade de usos e formas
de apropriação da cidade inclusive e
principalmente aquelas que não geram um
lucro que não remunera o capital que não
geram juros para aquele investidor todas
essas formas que são formas
absolutamente necessárias para a
reprodução da vida da cidade em
processos individuais e coletivos
elas são preteridos em relação àquela
forma de ocupação do espaço capaz de
gerar a maior rentabilidade o maior juro
para o investimento que ali aportou essa
já tem sido a lógica de organização da
cidade no âmbito dos espaços privados
dos lotes privados dos imóveis privados
a gente vive isso no nosso cotidiano é
muito tempo nesse sentido qual é a
novidade no sentido de que o mercado
imobiliário vai se apropriando
a dis vai gerando localização estou
falando dos lotes privados do pedaço
privado da cidade e que à medida que as
cidades que a gente vai fazendo
investimentos na cidade aquelas
localizações vão valorizando e à medida
que aquelas localizações vão valorizando
no mercado você tem um mercado que rege
a constituição do espaço privado da
cidade ele vai esse mercado capturando
determinados espaços para usos que
conseguem pagar mais por exemplo o uso
comercial consegue pagar mais do que o
residencial em geral porque usa
localização para fazer render então a
gente vê bairros inteiros que eram
residências no comércio começa a
penetrar e vai ganhando espaço e vai
expulsando o uso residencial ou um uso
mais verticalizada em relação ao uso né
de casas e sobrados exceto eu não estou
dizendo que isso é justo que isso é
certo
só estou dizendo que aí a presença dessa
lógica dentro do mercado privado e que
no baniyas no planejamento urbano uma
das missões é exatamente introduzir
elementos para contrarrestar essa lógica
que pelo simples mercado vai destinar
sempre os lotes para quem puder pagar
mais e portanto quem pode pagar - tá
fora né então o planejamento urbano tem
instrumentos pelo menos deveria ter
instrumentos para tentar equilibrar
garantindo que mesmo os usos menos
rentáveis com menos capacidade de pagar
aquela rentabilidade do lado privado
como por exemplo habitação popular
habitação social é de quem não pode
pagar pudessem mesmo assim existe na
cidade e ocupar espaços relativamente
organizados e equipados e não como é
matriz histórica nossa né da nossa
política habitacional que habitação
popular fica sempre jogada
não cidade longe da cidade longe das
oportunidades submetendo então as
pessoas aí a gente vai falando dos
direitos né casa não é só quatro paredes
um teto que haja é um portal a partir do
qual você acessa cidade ou deixa de
fechar a cidade então não é indiferente
onde ela tá se ela está no meio do mato
onde judas perdeu as botas ou se ela
está num lugar central com as
oportunidades a mão ou perto de um
parque ou perto de uma área de lazer
então ela acaba é submetida simplesmente
a lógica do mercado acaba sendo sempre
excluída das melhores localizações eu
falei tudo isso para dizer que não é
sobre isso que eu quero falar eu quero
falar sobre uma coisa muito mais
perversa que isso já é suficientemente
perverso como eu acabei de dizer porque
ela exclui uma parte da população da sua
possibilidade de desenvolvimento humano
e pessoal na medida em que ela pode
acessar as cidades que é um artefato uma
obra coletiva incrível né que é capaz de
alimentar a alma das pessoas com as
oportunidades culturais econômicas e
educacionais
eu estou falando dos espaços públicos
neste momento o que está em jogo aqui
esta lógica que já era corrente nos
espaços privados é exportada para o
espaço público até pública que no fundo
era talvez a única oportunidade dentro
dessa lógica de você poder usar uma
parte do território para usos não
estáveis já que toda a área privada vai
ser estruturada pela lógica dos usos
rentáveis à terra pública o espaço
público é o grande fillon do que da
possibilidade de ofertar espaços
equipamentos lugares pra vida
indistintamente da renda distintamente
do gênero indistintamente
gerência sexual né e ou da cor
então esses lugares públicos
hoje o que está colocado como política
pública e eu vou falar ah ah o termo em
inglês
a lógica do espaço público também passa
a ser a lógica da rentabilidade ou seja
pra que serve a terra pública para ser
vendido pelo maior valor
isso pra terra pública do terreno
público para que serve um equipamento
público para que ele ofereça
oportunidades de investimento e
rentabilidade para capitais financeiros
internacionais que capitais financeiros
internacionais excedentes acumulados no
planeta que estão permanentemente em
busca dessas oportunidades de
investimento para dali poder está aí
ainda trabalhe poderes traz juros para
continuarem como uma nuvem negra com o
capital excedente global circulando
sobre o planeta em busca de novas
oportunidades para extrair renda para
extrair lucro para né juros para
constituir um capital excedente global
eu podia terminar todo o tempo da minha
fala reproduzido por que nós estamos
falando de um circuito financeiro cujo
único objetivo é aumentar e crescer cada
vez mais que não tem nenhum compromisso
com a possibilidade de ofertar melhor
qualidade melhor acesso a direitos para
as pessoas
a eds eliminação das oportunidades das
pessoas e submeter o espaço público a
lógica e as necessidades desse capital
ou seja oferecer numa banda ginha toma
leva o que você prefere
esse parque você prefere o edifício da
prefeitura
você prefere aquele lugar àquele centro
irão para explorar significa
simplesmente elimina a possibilidade que
acho que é uma possibilidade que tem que
ser defendida permanentemente na cidade
de que uma parte importante do espaço
urbano tem que servir só presente se
viver e usar e no tem que render
absolutamente nada tem que acolher os
nossos desejos de estar nossos desejos
de conviver nossos desejos de poder nos
desenvolver como pessoa mas também como
grupo como indivíduo mas também como
grupo e portanto não podem ficar
subordinados pura e simplesmente a
lógica do consumo eles visitem para que
possam ser consumidos e eles existem pra
que eles constituem uma nova frente de
expansão né de oportunidades pra esse é
o capital financeiro não estamos falando
de perdas que podem ser perdas
irreparáveis na medida em que nós não
vamos reproduzir mais e mais e mais
e se esse essa terra pública esse ativo
né aliás é funcionar até a publicar
equipamento público de ativo já tem tudo
a ver com a lógica da financeirização do
espaço da utilização do espaço como um
elemento da do circuto né da circulação
do circuito é financeiro e não a
utilização do espaço como lugar de viver
como lugar de existir como lugar de
celebrar como lugar de ser eu não posso
terminar minha fala alguém falou que tem
um computador quer dizer quantos minutos
mas eu não estou vendo é não posso
terminar minha fala sem relacionar isso
há um movimento há dois movimentos muito
recentes que a gente verifica na cidade
de são paulo que eu acho que
muito importantes e vão na contramão de
tudo isso que eu falei até agora a gente
observou na cidade principalmente a
partir dos anos 90 o movimento da cidade
de saída e de abandono das pessoas em
relação aos espaços públicos às ruas as
praças
o stark se um pouco tem um contexto
amplo que não vai dar para desenvolver
por que isso ocorreu nem mas a rua ou
parque visto como um lugar inseguro como
um lugar não cuidado e teve a ver com a
conjuntura dos anos 90 onde o país viveu
um ajuste fiscal muito parecido do que
está vivendo agora a dificuldade
manutenção desses espaços
o aumento né da criminalidade e da
insegurança tem a ver com todo esse
movimento de modo que uma cidade como
são paulo e muitas outras
a gente foi deixando de tirar os
comerciais para ter shopping centers
deixando de ter bairros residenciais
prater condomínios fechados deixando de
ter é um tipo de equipamento diretamente
relacionado à rua os cinemas de rua os
hiatos de rua para tudo se configurar
com o que a gente chama de enclaves
enclaves fortificados murados vigiados e
aí foi explodindo esse tipo de
utilização
eu quero chamar a atenção para vocês de
como esse movimento começou a sofrer um
movimento contrário
isso não foi nem resultado de política
pública não foi o resultado do movimento
das pessoas dos cidadãos dos moradores
da cidade que começaram em junho
primeiro botando barzinho mesinhas de
barzinho de mesa na calçada e começando
a ficar na calçada e depois se
apropriando e começando a frequentar
para aceitar qui e depois se apaixonando
pelas praças e parques e começando a
cuidar deles com amor e com vivendo ali
descobrindo o que
conviver com o heterogêneo e depois foi
se apropriando dos espaços públicos das
cidades das ruas e aí percebeu que elas
eram dos carros aí percebeu que elas
eram só do circuito do consumo e
começaram a tensionar né com esse
movimento no sentido de capturar e se
apropriar desses lugares roubando dos
carros roubando do tempo da circulação e
do consumo e estabelecendo uma outra
forma de existência e convivência nesses
espaços públicos 'extermínio' a minha
fala pra dizer que é uma contradição
enorme entre esse movimento dos
moradores na procura da convivência na
procura de uma cidade que não é só a
cidade do trabalho do consumidor à
circulação mas é a cidade do prazer é a
cidade da produção cultural da invenção
da criação da convivência e uma política
que só admite a idéia da gestão do
espaço se ele for rentável ou se eles se
transformar de alguma forma num objeto
de consumo
então me parece que nós estamos numa
encruzilhada muito importante a onde é
absolutamente necessário agora perceber
esse movimento que nós moradores fizeram
ninguém vento não foi uma política
pública que decretou nós nós fizemos nós
pra que esse movimento nosso não seja
tatuado por uma lógica aonde aquilo que
a gente construiu como espaço de
convivência seja colocado numa
prateleira à venda numa bandeja elevado
que os investidores em dubai
obrigado
[Aplausos]